so here's spring which is my favorite oh
he looks pretty
he's really excited to be dressed as a
he's a beautiful boy
how did nolan never get around to this
guy well we'll get to that
we will get to that
nina what is the best and worst batman
villains that you want to see on the big
screen next
so in the interest of uh remaining
positive i don't have a best but i have
a worst
perfect um i did this
yeah i just wanted to dunk on a really
bad uh batman character so
i am going to go with a calendar man
who yeah i thought that was going to
happen
first um so calendar man is a villain
who
only commits crimes on specific holidays
he
absolutely sucks that's his entire
gimmick he did
technically appear in the lego batman
movie but we the
looper team decided that doesn't count
because everyone was in the lego batman
movie
that was the point right everybody was
in that so
i think that would be just i mean i just
don't want to see
a batman villain being like well it's
arbor day so i killed somebody with a
tree you know that's
that's i don't need that kind of
negativity in my life
it is kind of a tough sell for like a
guy
if his one weakness is being locked in a
room on specific days
yeah and it's like i mean i think
there's probably a way that you could
use them i will admit i have not yet
watched the animated harley quinn series
though i hear it's really really good
and apparently alan tudyk yeah alan
tudyk voices him
in this series i believe and i love alan
tudyk and if anybody could play in
on the big screen maybe it should be him
but i also really really don't want to
see calendar man pop up in the dc eu
in live form at all because
what a terrible villain he's tied to a
calendar
like you know when he's going to commit
a crime because there's a holiday coming
up
okay so i also picked calendar man
i knew it oh guys i haven't gone yet i'm
just co-opting because i have stuff
planned for calendar man i want to talk
about calendar i love it i love it so
i've shared in our chat
a the cover of his first appearance
in his first appearance back in the 50s
created by bill finger batman co-creator
bill finger
um he did crimes committed
based on the seasons they weren't
holiday specific yet
so his first appearance he get he
dresses up in five different outfits and
the first one
is on the cover um or at least the first
one you see it's on the cover
as you can see he is dressed like summer
so he's wearing a oh a uh an interesting
like a hazmat suit with a sun in the
middle of it
it's really nice uh it looks great i
would like one
dating is what it is so then this is on
page
on page one of that issue this is what
he looks like
he's dressed up like a snowman and so
i should also point out that in these
both of these appearances
when he's committing these crimes in
this one issue um
he has different so he's like this like
genius inventor he's like
doing like heat like he has heat powers
where he's like
shooting heat rays and flames and things
like that and then when he's
dressed as a snowman he's shooting snow
and ice and all that stuff
so winter summer oh i'm reading just
quickly i'm reading the page that you
sent us and it is extraordinary
i mean things were different in the 50s
let's just be honest they were at a
diamond exhibit a thing that definitely
happens in real life i will
i will i don't want to stop making fun
of this
but i will point out that the reason
that it is this ridiculous is because
after the comics code authority came
through
and said hey these comic books are
corrupting the youth
you have to make sure that kids are safe
reading these comic books they were like
okay so they basically made them silly
cartoons back in the fifties in the show
many decades to get a little a little
crazier no that
you're i mean that's an important thing
to note right that that comics were
silly for a reason yes yeah so okay but
anyway back to how stupid this looks
um so i'm sending now i'm i'm sharing
uh his outfit for autumn which
apparently
was so lame that they only show it like
from far away
so that's autumn and he has like a big
wind machine and he's throwing
he said that he's throwing leaves yeah
he looks like an extra from cirque du
soleil
and so here's my favorite one but not
the last one
and you're asking well there's four
seasons how could the fourth one not be
the last one
i'll get to that um nina thank you for
sharing yours
one of them is one of them awards season
yeah
does he dress up like a golden globe or
an oscar i'm sorry to say
you're not as far off as i'd like you to
be
so here's spring which is my favorite oh
he looks pretty
he's really excited to be dressed as a
he's a beautiful boy
yeah how did nolan never get around to
this guy well we'll get to that
we will get to that we're going to get
to a lot
so in this in this issue he's basically
committing crimes and he's taunting
batman he's like i'm going to commit
five crimes and he's dressing up as
these four seasons
and batman or robin can't figure out
what the deal is and then eventually
they figure out what the fifth season is
and they figure it out by seeing this
clue in the paper
calendar man dresses up as a as a an
indian magician
with a turban and says that the fifth
season is monsoon season
and he was going to steal some stuff i
guess using rain
and it's a pretty uh it's kind of
probably problematic
it's uh it's not really great oh yeah
and my favorite part i forgot yeah so
you're so you're all in shock but
but okay so here's um so how do you
think that batman defeats calendar man
this is actually beautiful and amazing i
gotta assume using
clues from a far side calendar like uh
like one of those daily things that he
ripped like maybe two
sassy cows does he just get i don't have
a good joke
tom you keep ripping i'll vape okay
uh let's see here he uh he he waits
uh for the mall where calendar man is
working to shut down he
um i got nothing how does how does
batman defeat this nefarious phone
does calendar man forget to write down
their battle in his calendar
he literally throws a calendar at him
he just throws a calendar at him and it
hits him in the legs and he falls down
and then it's over
um that's how the issue is i'm gonna
start doing this against my own enemies
it's just tossing wall calendars at them
and seeing what happens if you toss a
giant wall calendar at someone like a
big one that's like on a blackboard and
you just
throw that kind right at the back of
their knees
no it wasn't like a little little uh
mall calendar this is like a
big big cowboy i was thinking like you
know
like pugs and dresses or something you
know
like one of those little like novelty
calendars
so yeah so anyway that's how batman
takes out the calendar man now
with his own with his own calendar so
yeah so
it's well he who lives by the calendar
must also
so he's hoisted on his own calendar get
hit by
yeah outstanding so
first of all it's actually pretty pretty
clever
why do i like comic books second of all
that is not the end of calendar man's
story
certainly not how could it be
have either of you read batman the long
halloween
certainly have nina i have not but i
know that
i know something about it that i'm sure
you're going to arrive at most
which is that he shows up in the long
halloween
as basically a consultant that batman
and commissioner gordon talked to
to figure out who this new holiday
killer is
holiday so in the long halloween every
month goes by
and a holiday comes up and a serial
killer is out there
bumping off criminals and being bad and
committing crimes and so they're just
like
let's talk to calendar man he might know
something about this
and it's the only time that calendar
man's been cool and interesting
he does show up in the um i believe it's
batman arkham city
i don't think he's in the first one but
he shows up and he's just kind of
basically inspired by this different
look of
a bald creepy weirdo who is in a cell
who is obsessed with calendars
and he's got the he's got the little
months like all around the city he's
carved them into his head
yeah that's in the second one um dark
victory he shows up with that tattoo
situation but at the end of the day
it's as far as i know the only
interesting use of calendar man and it's
only to be
uh involved in discussing the crimes of
someone who does the same thing as him
but better and more interestingly
i gotta say that's like that's my
favorite trope in batman comics is that
like
if somebody shows up and starts
committing a very specific crime
they're always like well the only person
who could have any insight into this
is this lunatic this guy committed a
crime while he was asking questions
so we should go talk to the guy who only
wears bowler hats and has a cane and he
spins around
everything's a riddle that's yeah no
you're right he's probably got some some
really great
yeah yeah he probably has some really
unique insights also uh brian i'm
guessing you're aware that
there in march of this year they
announced a two-part uh
long halloween movie in which calendar
man will appear
so it's it's for sure official that he
is actually going to appear
i mean in march of this year hollywood
reporter set the voice cast he'll be
voiced by an actor named david del
das malshen um oh the uh the polka dot
man
yeah yeah i don't know how to say his
name i'm we're gonna get
we're gonna get we're gonna get on
screen we're going to have them say yeah
this is how you get
they'll correct us yeah we need that
maybe we'll take maybe we'll maybe we'll
take a break
and we'll have someone say his name in
voiceover
right here david does mochin
that's how you say it i didn't know it
but it was coming out that was amazing
yeah right exactly so now that we know
how to say
i was close yeah i mean that's a really
great pick but
oh will this movie be on the big screen
or it's animated
it's an animated movie so that's why i
went with calendar man because
as of right now there are unsurprisingly
no plans to have
a live-action big-screen villain be
calendar man uh and apparently he was
supposed to be in gotham which is also
not big screen it's a television show
but
that did not happen and i can't imagine
why they were just like yeah calendar
man is
still somehow too ridiculous for this
ridiculous yeah they were like this is
the very bottom of the barrel and we've
got other
scrapings to pull off the mad hatter for
example
exactly somebody much less ridiculous
so that is my pick and i'm glad that uh
brian
that brian had so much insight because
it was also his pick i'm sorry
i'm sorry i felt like i stepped all over
your choice oh no
please i need i need the the brian rubin
uh comic book lore wisdom to back up my
point about why calendar man sucks
calendar man does suck he sucks
yeah teamwork makes the dream work brian
i feel like didn't they give calendar
man like
crazy superpowers recently like he he
sheds his skin
and like hatches a new body out of his
old carapace
like this is this i will say i have no
idea
but i will also say that given given
recent dc
comics developments that would not
surprise me at all do you think
anybody's done like a calendar man story
where he
like kind of gets overwhelmed by the
number of just stupid social media
holidays that are happening now where
he's just killing someone every single
day because he's like it's national
waffle day it will talk like a pirate
day
right yeah no that that he's at a spirit
halloween store every day just picking
out new crappy costumes just trying to
catch up that's a that's a good way to
to defeat him you invite him to your
facebook
like you invite him as a facebook friend
and you just start filling the calendar
with different
you know oh man stupid just let him wear
that
he'd be totally overloaded he'd never be
able to get all that done
yeah and he'd just be too tired he'd
just be like african
that's fine i'm tired just thinking
about it
[Laughter]
do you think he ever tries to confuse
batman by going with a lunar calendar
and they're like what holidays are these
oh no chinese holidays
jewish holidays look out batman yeah
i love this this is i think we should be
hired to write this dc should call us i
mean now i'm ready to see him on the big
screen
i think it's going to be great because
we've got a cracker idea
yeah yeah okay that's enough about caleb
i'm giving
the tagline what else i'm giving up
batman for lent yeah anyway go on
tom who do you have okay for me uh
i don't know i'm of several minds about
this one because i i love batman i've
loved batman since i was a kid
uh the villains are always if not the
best part than the dorkiest part
and i and i think they really only fall
into those two categories they're
either just so cool or the absolute
worst
uh and i think both of those things have
uh have merit
so my number one choice for the best
villain that i would love to see brought
into the
the big screen and especially if we're
going to keep going grim with it the way
that it kind of seems like the
the robert pattinson movie is going to
go
i would love to see king tut
specifically i would love to see king
tut done
basically exactly the same way that they
did in the 60s tv show
if you're not familiar king cut was the
guy who got hit in the head with a brick
and then woke up this is true this is
all this is none of this is made of
uh i mean it's all made up it's ben
he got hit in the head with a brick he
woke up convinced that he was king cut
and then somehow managed to finance this
like
extravagant lifestyle entirely based
around like you know hiring goons to
dress up as his underlings and like it's
all ancient egyptian theme
he makes like a jackal god statue and
it's made out of solid gold with like
with booby traps built into it and he
and he releases it in gotham just hoping
the batman's going to show up
i would love to see like that level of
it is
it is great nina i'm glad that you
recognized that oh
i think this could be oscar bate
right you know who should you so do do
we agree about who should play king tut
steve martin that is the answer i was
looking for thank you nina
i was hoping that someone was going to
say and he's he's older now so he could
play it really crappy
you know just but also exactly like he
did on snl
yeah just a lot of this a lot of the
funky tut but he's like old
and kind of like terrifying in that way
yeah i've always wanted to see steve
martin in a batman movie so this is how
i make my dreams come true
it's the only way let's make it happen
again like uh he's another one that he
showed up in the lego batman movie just
as a sight gag thing but the guy who
originally played him
victor buono i think was his name just
yeah i mean he's the same as everybody
else who
did stuff on the old batman series he's
just chewing scenery the whole time
just like these this grand rule and uh
yeah no so i i don't know something
about
inserting that into this like very
self-serious franchise that just cannot
cannot stop trying to convince us the
the
story about a rich guy who dresses up as
his favorite animal and punches people
is
is worth our emotions was king tut also
in the comics
no they made him specifically for the uh
for the show he's
shown up in the comics is again like as
kind of a gag character since got it
okay yeah all right but no he's uh
just just delightfully the worst i
i support that idea i love it i think
it's a great pick
i want to see it if we are going to go
like just like straight dark i think
that uh professor pig would be a great
option uh
okay yeah do you want to tell us about
that professor pig is a relatively new
addition to the batman rogues gallery
well that sounds dark
just from the name alone it's one of
those things that sounds kind of
ridiculous when you just say it
absent any kind of context but tom do
you want to explain who professor pig is
and what his deal is
i want to say they came up with them for
one of the cartoons but i'm
positive that we'll put in kind of a
snotty caption underneath me if i'm
wrong right now
i will correct you now based on my
understanding of it i believe that he
was invented by grant morrison
i want to say maybe you know what 15
years ago
during when he took over and professor
pig was one of the early villains that
he did
like they don't really set him up very
much but he's just this
this creepy guy wearing a pig head
who does actually can we get like the
can we get the caption that's correcting
me anyway or just like calling you yeah
no i want to well cool
wait i i have a question about professor
pig okay what's your question
was he also hit in the head with any
bricks
that's a valve inevitably right i mean
like the context of this
is important to me i am a scholar of
this
i'm learning yeah how many bricks are
responsible for the origins of batman
villains how many times were they hit in
the head and then
that's what i need to know this is this
is what the people oh
so like the masons are actually
responsible for it
oh my god you can't say that in the
video they're going to come for us it's
not that far from court of owls i think
we got this thing
pretty much figured out anyway so he's
uh he's he's based on the idea is uh
he's kind of based on the the myth of
pygmalion and uh
right his whole goal is that he wants to
turn people into their perfect forms
which he does you know
obviously by chopping them up and uh
wondering how we were going to get to
pygmalion
from that cyg hey yeah
yeah yeah uh it's a stretch but no it i
mean like
it's a weird guy it is a stretch it'll
be probably
i would wager that they'd probably bring
him into a movie in maybe another
10 or 20 years he hasn't been around
long enough to be a classic character
but
i wouldn't be surprised if he joins do
you think they would
change his name because professor pig
does sound so silly
do you think i mean come up with
something that sounds menacing i mean
in in dark knight they had the joker
they they're gonna have the riddler you
know
everyone yeah but everyone knows who the
joker is no one was like that doesn't
sound like a real villain
i think i think if you pair some of the
visuals of professor pig
in the marketing and you just you know
you don't have to go out of your way to
say like in this movie
batman fights sure sure yeah it'll still
be
creepy and menacing enough that you'll
probably
yeah i think it would work i think it
would work you get like the the overhead
lighting
and the uh yeah i'm just here to make 30
rock references
and all i'm thinking about is when jenna
maroney is filming a low budget horror
movie in stamford connecticut and
there's a guy in a pig mask torturing
her
basically great public libraries that's
what i'm
envisioning so that's fine i can roll
with that that sounds good well so now
we know that it works it can be creepy
yeah yeah you just need the right
context
thanks tina exactly perfect so my pick
my pick for for worst was calendar man
my pick for best is the ventriloquist
i think it would be hot yes it is i
think he's fantastic
no you don't agree
no make your case okay so the
ventriloquist
is basically i love this idea because he
is
a person who's uh basically
so his his identity is so fractured
that all of his aggression and anger and
malevolence
is channeled through a ventriloquist
dummy which is dressed up like a little
a little gangster man and he is
literally the gangster's right-hand man
because he's got his
hand in the gangster everyone knows that
the ventriloquist is the person
controlling
the puppet and yet the way in which
they're portrayed
makes it menacing enough that they are
two separate characters
the ventriloquist and scarface um
and it's so strange of
of an idea and so simple and classic i
love it because it's
it really harkens back to you know
batman was created in 1939
he was inspired by the shadow and so
you've got these great pulpy
villains these bad guys like the joker
like
two-face you know these are characters
who we've all kind of come to except as
classic batman villains and you've got
this dude the ventriloquist who's
created in the 70s
um and he just belongs in that old
school old style pulpy batman bad guy
villain
he is legitimately menacing and creepy
if done right
and i just think it it fits so well with
batman's
villains kind of weird strange
predilections for obsessing on singular
things
and i love that this guy is is
is meek and yet he's he's still the bat
he's still the bad guy he's ultimately
in control
and i think that they could do a really
good job with it going off of your idea
um if if we were to get a sequel to the
the matt reeves batman
throw the ventriloquist in there just
some nut who carries this dummy around
and i love how they did it in the batman
animated series i know i've been talking
a long time with no one interrupting and
that's
a little worrying but that's okay i'm
just gonna keep going because
well you've sold me i'm gonna interrupt
you and tell you that you've sold me
no because i i find ventriloquists
creepy
ventriloquist dummies are super creepy
so yeah i don't like them
in the original animated in the batman
animated series from the 90s they did a
story with that
and before you you know that it's it's a
ventriloquist with a dummy
you just think that there's some little
tiny gangster who's in control who's
being carried around
i hate that by this man with glasses and
then eventually i'm not familiar with
that story and i never want to be
familiar with that story
it's great like sleeping at night it's
super good so
nina did you just use somebody being
tiny
i'm just i'm worried about you as well
seems like a self-loathing thing
well yeah well i'm not um
masquerading as a tiny gangster who's
being operated by a meek
sidekick not yet we don't know that
about you
who knows what's going to happen next
week the next month it might happen but
anyway
um that's my pick i really like the
ventriloquist as a concept i'm not going
to say he's like one of my favorite
characters but he is a super weird one
and he's pretty obscure i think that's i
think that's also good because it's like
i don't think it i doubt anyone was like
scarecrow would make a great creepy
villain right and he does
right so i don't see why ventriloquist
couldn't work as well and it's the kind
of thing where it only
olin made scarecrow really creepy yeah
and it's a totally
it's a very grounded for you know in a
way
grounded character there's nothing
supernatural there's no superpowers
going on
it's just somewhere i like that yeah
it's just this really great gimmick for
this
this villainous character and i just i
just love it so that's my picture tom
still seems unconvinced
i guess i just like what i'm struggling
with is the physicality of the character
like how do you make him an
imposing threat if this whole thing is
that he's like kind of a doughy guy
have you ever seen a jeff dunham's
stand-up special
i have and i've also seen a lot of
people who are very eager to punch him
afterwards i don't understand how
exactly what a great villain all right
yeah no
soul i got it i'm in
also sorry jeff dunham i have nothing
against you i feel bad
because i know that he's watching yeah
he's using every week
he's a big looper fan jeff dunham and
peanut peanuts
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
video
you